okay hi
i am debbie cohen i chair the terry
lectures committee as well as the
program in history of science and
medicine here
last year the terry committee launched a
new series the terry forums
in order to bring together scholars and
students from across the campus to
reflect on questions about ethical
knowledge making that cut across the
disciplines
the forum is intended to be a space
where we can learn from each other in a
spirit of mutual respect for our
differences
our speaker today i am delighted to say
is charmaine royal
as you can see here she is the robert
cayenne professor of african and african
american studies biology global health
and family medicine and community health
and as she put it at lunch she is all
about interdisciplinarity
as that mouthful suggests
as i also learned at lunch today
professor royal grew up in jamaica
wanting to become a physician
came to the u.s for college to howard
university
and took her first genetics course and
became fascinated by the subject
though the questions that seemed most
pressing to her even back then questions
about the science's ethical framework
and its entanglement with racism didn't
yet have a clear disciplinary home
and ever since she has been at the
forefront of crafting new methods and
networks to pursue those questions
she went on to earn a master's degree in
genetic counseling and a doctorate in
human genetics from howard then
completed post-graduate training in
ethical legal and social implications
research and bioethics at the national
human genome research institute at the
nih
and epidemiology and behavioral medicine
back at howard
and today she directs the duke center on
genomics race identity and difference
and the duke center for truth racial
healing and transformation
her research scholarship and teaching
focus on ethical social scientific and
clinical implications of human genetics
and genomics particularly issues at the
intersection of genetics and race
and she also serves a numerous national
and international advisory boards and
committees for government agencies
professional organizations research
initiatives not-for-profit entities and
corporations
and as i've learned has a very busy
travel schedule so we're very grateful
to her for making time to visit new
haven
our moderator today is
professor brandon ogbunu
who teaches in the department of ecology
and evolutionary biology here
and is also a member of the terry
committee and he uses experimental
evolution mathematical modeling and
computational biology to better
understand the underlying causes and
consequences of disease across scales
and also writes frequently for
non-academic audiences on a wide range
of topics and with great wit and you can
find his articles
in venues like wired medium and
scientific american
and i also want to acknowledge
professor obunu and professor tom near
as the co-organizers of the event today
professor nir
is the chair of ecology and evolutionary
biology he's also the bingham
oceanographic curator of theology at the
peabody museum
and head of college at sabre college and
he mentioned to me that he was inspired
to help organize this event because
he grew up quote eyes wide open in the
united states and is eager to include
these topics in
the biology curriculum here at yale in
particular in the sequence of courses
that every pre-med student and biology
major takes in yale college
thank you to my co-organizers
and please join me in welcoming
professor royal
well thank you
and thank you
brandon and
tom and all those who invited me here
um i am delighted to be here i was
telling them that it's been a long time
since i've been to yale
my sister did her post-graduate work
here in the 90s and that probably was
the last time i was at yale
so it's great to be back
um
the ethics of knowledge making
i was fascinated by that
um and i can't think of
too many other topics
where
making knowledge
requires us to think about
the ethical issues related to the making
of that knowledge
as race
and racism
and today i'm going to talk about
historical we're going to do a little
bit of history and i have a bunch of
history of science people in here i'm
not going to get into the details but
just
do a cursory overview of some of the
key
milestones in the creation of this idea
of race and the racism that goes along
with that
um i'm gonna
present some data from some of my work
on how people think about race and
um
i
have developed an
interest in looking at different
um
groups different i don't want to call
them stakeholder groups different
interest groups and how they think about
this i've looked at geneticists
anthropologists
general population
and clinicians and i'm going to present
some of those data in terms of
how they think
about this concept of race and the
plight
in their work
and then i'm going to talk a little bit
about
race-based medicine
and some of the challenges with that and
i'm going to i have some case studies
after talking about
the perspectives of some of these groups
i'm going to do some case studies i'm
going to talk a bit about sickle cell
disease which is one of my areas of work
and then talk a bit about race-based
medicine and some of some of the the
issues that are arising now
in terms of how we do medicine how we
practice medicine utilizing concepts of
race and the questions about where do we
go from here and how do we and whether
we not use race anymore and then i'm
going to wrap up that sounds like two
days of talks
then i'm gonna wrap up
by talking a little bit about how i
teach about race and racism and giving
an example
of a course that i call my signature
course that i teach at duke um that is a
course that the students energize me i
hope as much as i inspire them
so that's
the frame for what we're going to do
today
so when i think of history one of the
first people that come to my mind is
john hope franklin
who was a professor at duke he also was
a professor at howard which is where i
got all my degrees so we have a lot in
common he also loves orchids and i'm an
orchid connoisseur as well so we have a
quite a bit in common
but in his
one of his
most
widely read
books
from slavery to freedom
he made this statement
if the house is to be set in order
we cannot begin
with the present
we must begin with the past
and so we're going to do a little bit of
past because the past
is what informs how we deal with the
present and the future
so i'm going to go through a few slides
um
with
again
not an exhaustive history
of race and and the idea of race but
just some
points that
i think are relevant to what we're going
to talking about so in terms of people
thinking about i guess i could take my
mask off can i
all right
that'll be better for you and for me
so
in thinking about
race and the creation of the idea of
course as we know race and racism
has everything to do with people and how
people see each other so once people and
and in this case uh european mostly
explorers back in the 15th century and
probably before started engaging with
people who looked
differently
from them
uh those ideas of who are these people
why are they different how are they
different
started to percolate so we have the
european explorers we have the start of
the transatlantic slave trade the
movement of people across um the
atlantic um from different parts of
africa going to
um to other parts of of the world and so
those ideas started to percolate but in
the in the 18th century
um we had scientists
also doing their thing
in their labs and wherever they did them
in their homes wherever these ideas came
came from we had carlos linnaeus
mr taxonomy um who started grouping
humans based on geography and came up
with his his four-part grouping there
um and then later on we have
bloomingbach who who many not all
credit or discredit with the creation of
this idea of race in terms of the
hierarchies
that we have and so we have blooming
bach his dissertation work and then
later publications
creating these categories
and um becoming one of the first and
there were other people doing this
around that time but he is one of the
key ones in terms of creating this
hierarchy based on what he viewed as the
most beautiful people from the caucasus
mountains and putting
one of the people who came up with the
word caucasian
and then putting everybody else
below and then we have thomas jefferson
third president of the u.s
being one of the first prominent
u.s leaders to actually put forward this
idea
that
people
who we call
uh
black people
people of african descent
are less
than
are inferior to
um
to to people who we call in the us at
least who we call
whites
um so one of the first people to start
using these you see he talks about
species and taking from the scientists
work and bringing it into how society
starts to think about people and
difference
and we have the first census in 1790 and
and you may not be able to
read this i don't expect you to read all
of it but what i want you to see this is
created by the scent
developed by the census in 2012
um showing how categories certain
categories have changed since the first
census in 1790 where race was
used in the census and you see the
categories there and this shows how
these categories have changed over time
right over time they have changed the
one category in the census that has not
changed does anybody know which category
has not really changed over all these
years from 1790 to 2. i cut it off
because it was too big so it stopped
there but if you go to that website it's
an interactive
resource you can click on these and it
gives you all the information click on
any of these and you get more
information click on the dates you get
more information about all of those
identities does anybody know anybody can
tell me
somebody
white
has not changed
who belongs to that group has changed
right who can be included and excluded
has changed over time but the category
itself has not all these other
categories have changed and you see
where chinese came in mostly from
immigration right we get a lot of
information just from this from this
graphic
and so the census and i show the census
and i mention the sensors because the
census is key to how we think about race
right and when we look at the u.s census
today
the categories that we use in the senses
very much mirror blooming back
box taxonomies
very much right now we're saying we need
to move away we don't use caucasian in
the census anymore in the u.s but we did
right it was there it's not there
anymore different countries as we know
have different senses and most of what i
talk about today because we don't have
time to get into the global aspects of
race which uh could take us in some
other directions um but but
over time
the these these uh have changed but the
census becomes important because we use
it in research we use those categories
in research we use it in clinical we use
them in clinical care and the questions
about why and how and whether we ought
to use them or some of the big questions
and then we have darwin father
revolution of evolution and his writings
um
on the original species
and then descent of man and in descent
of man he actually became one of the
first people and there are lots of
things we could say about darwin and
we're not going to talk a lot about
darwin today but one of the the first
prominent scientists
to to question this notion of the
existence of human races right
eugenics
have cousin of of of of um of darwin
galton actually coined the term and
brought that whole movement in and
charles davenport
who started the eugenics record office
here in the u.s
in in 1910
at cold springs harbor
so eugenics became a thing and
um and people will
will
argue that we still have eugenics today
not so much arguably we still have it in
all kinds of forms um so eugenics as a
as a movement and in the early 19th
early 20th century to mid-20th centuries
there was a series of debates
among anthropologists and biologists
montague and [ __ ] and brace and
livingston and
about just very similar to those debates
we're having right now about race and
the existence of race and ethnicity and
what they are and what they're not and
what biology
says about them
and then we have richard london
um from harvard who in the 1970s
did studies looking at blood group
antigens and and and looking at
populations across the the world
and there are all kinds of things we
could say about those studies he did in
the 70s but
he was his studies were some of the
first ones to tell us a bit about
genetic variation biological variation
right among populations and told us that
most of the genetic variation we see
is within populations about 85 percent
or so of genetic variation can be found
within populations
and
very little variation
between
populations
and then the human genome project
that
confirmed
some of lewinton's work and some of the
previous work that as humans
as a human species we're more alike than
we're different um
99.9 percent the same we say uh as
humans and around the time of the human
genome project
before just before it ended and after we
had other scientists that were using
different kinds of methods alan
templeton in 19 in the 90s and and and
early 2000s
used right statistic which is a a
methodology of looking at genetic
variation right and geneticists
population geneticists still use right
statistic and using that statistic as a
measure of genetic variation looking at
variation within population within
individual groups and then as as a
measure of and looking at their in
relation to the globe the broader
population and looking at humans in
relation to other organisms
and um
and concluding that humans
have very little variation
within the group genetic variation so
again
right statistic
less than 0.25 when you look across the
human genome we're saying probably about
0.156 in terms of this particular
statistic very low
variation within the population and the
statistic used generally says
if their variation is if the right
statistic is below 0.25 then we can say
humans don't have biological race and
when i say biological
race
and i know that we have some
evolutionary
people in here and there are all kinds
of of ideas and theories about how we
think about race and for some
evolutionary biologists race is
synonymous synonymous with subspecies
which is a level of divergence below the
level of the species and when we look at
humans we don't see that level of
divergence in terms of variation right
and so using a biological
measure
we can say humans don't have biological
race right but what people often say
is that
um
biological race doesn't exist right
and many in in evolutionary biology
would say it does it just doesn't exist
in humans right many will say for some
organisms and if you look here you'll
say and again we could debate this but
many will say for some organisms you
could say they have biological race
because of the amount of variation
within those populations but for humans
we don't
and there are other studies that show
talk about that that give us information
about the origins of humans
and this one by um
by um
john november and colleagues that that
confirmed studies that we had already
seen about the common origin the african
origin of humans
again confirming that we are one species
one origin same people we don't have
biological variation to that rises to
the level
of of subspecies or the level of race so
we say there's no biological race in
humans and these are four criteria and
they there may be more some may add
others to it but these are four criteria
that we often use in genetics and um and
some other sciences just to to say
that humans don't have biological race
we look at geographic variation when we
look at populations globally there's no
place that we can say one population
starts and the other one and variation
is overlapping it's continuous
and they're not these discrete
boundaries
gene frequency low intense showed us and
other studies have shown us more genetic
variation within groups than between
morphology which is one of the big
markers that we use
uh to define race
and i'll talk about social race in a
minute but we used to define race
when we look at morphology
we see
non-concordance
you know what people call kinky here
doesn't necessarily go
with dark skin
right or with a broad nose or all these
features that we tied to races uh
they're not
obligatory linked to each other or to
disease right we can see people with
blonde hair blue eyes in sierra leone or
in in in in the solomon islands in other
places um from europe different from
europe and then lineage as i said before
no
subspecies
no
um
um separate lineages within humans it's
one one lineage one species so using
these criteria we say
humans don't have biological race some
people will say race does not exist
right race does not exist in humans but
that's not exactly true we don't have
biological race based on these data that
i just present
but social race exists because we've
created it it exists
and it has real implications
on people's lives
the problem is that we conflate those
two things right which which is which is
the reason for the seminar today it's
like what is race is it biological is it
social how do we distinguish those two
things and how we do resolve the
complications that come from from
linking those two things so saying
biological race exists but not in humans
socially defined or socially constructed
race is real
we've created it and it has impacts on
people's lives including biological
influence impacts and influences right
so distinguishing those two things is
critical as we think about
about race what does biology say about
race what do humans have to say about
what we've created that we call race
right
so i
um as i said before
have become as the more i study race is
more
um
i have become interested in in in
getting real empirical data about what
people
think and people who will use this
information people who are using and
developing studies and so some
colleagues and i colleagues at
university of washington like bamshad
and others
did a study a few years ago
looking at anthropologists
and geneticists anthropology
professionals and genetics professionals
and we surveyed large numbers and you
see here
where we started invite who was invited
and then we got for geneticists we have
1500 anthropologists we invited 4 000 we
ended up with 300 3 000 and something
and then written comments so i'm going
to just show you some of the data that
we got and then some of the quantitative
as well as qualitative and we've
published these studies um one of them
is still in progress in terms of the
quantitative study for geneticists but
i'm going to show you some data that
compare the perspectives between
geneticists and anthropologists and i
show you those showed you those four
criteria that we use to say um
race races um
humans don't have biological
race
but as we know in the field and i'm a
geneticist
i know within the field of human
genetics
there is even though we say there is
consensus
you know their differences of opinion
and these data showed us that
and so these are these are some
of those data so what we did mike
bamshit and i we picked some statements
that we call common statements and these
are statements that people make all the
time and they'll say you know
geneticists agree on this or don't agree
on this and these are some of these
races don't exist race has no biological
basis
race is biologically meaningless
as we asked this we and the surveys were
the same for both the geneticists and
the anthropologists but just changing
them accordingly in terms of when we
asked them about their disciplines and
and all of that that's the only part
that was different in terms of
demographics but everything was the same
what do you notice anybody what do you
notice when you look at these data
huh
exact opposite right
right um
i i will say that most of the
anthropologists were cultural
anthropologists which might not surprise
us right the geneticists were mostly
um
clinical geneticists and genetic
counselors but we had molecular
geneticist population geneticists as
well
so that might have something to do what
we're seeing but what we see here is
exact opposite responses right
all right and just for it i'm just going
to show some of the quantitative data
qualitative data i may not be able to
show i have a bunch of quotes this came
from a geneticist geneticists who say
that race doesn't exist or denial
obviously they have never looked at the
results of an ames ancestry informative
markers that's what that is
um panel on a thousand african americans
and a thousand european caucasians
and clearly the outmoded racial
identifiers work more often than it
fails that's the science regardless of
anyone's opinion right it's a geneticist
um we asked the question
and this is something i've long been
interested in and i've actually written
on this that we should replace race i've
re-thought that i wrote that paper in
2006 and you know i have some thoughts
about changing that um i still think we
need to get rid of it but i think some
things i wrote in that paper i might i
might have said differently
um but the question of whether we need
to do away with race and replace it with
something else so these were some of the
questions we we asked and in general
you see that there's some agreement that
we need to come up with something else
apart from race right
well you know as we as
work has moved forward over the years
um there are those who have been asking
and wondering whether we're asking the
right questions right we're asking use
race don't use race
as if those are the only two options
right there may be questions that we
haven't asked
when should we use race why
how right those are those are the the
problems some of the questions that we
need to ask
um instead of
dichotomizing it the way we have but i'm
not i'm not quite there yet but i'm
getting there
um
uh so
raises a four-letter word that needs to
be retired and removed from the
dictionary and common um use as an
anthropologist and human geneticist i
have watched as modern methods of
measuring variation in humans have made
the word a 19th century anachronism
with no scientific
uh value i'm going to jump over to some
of these
the question of how
how we take this information to health
care
these based on how we think about about
race the knowledge the information we
know that biological race does not exist
but we see these health differences how
do we reconcile uh those things and then
there was somebody who's just like you
know forget this this human business
i just don't have to deal with this
uh forgetting that they're part of
society and they got to deal with it too
right
all right so in thinking about looking
at the general population so we did a
surveys colleagues at unc chapel hill
and myself and colleagues at duke
did a survey a national survey of the
u.s population
we had about 1700 people a
representative sample of the u.s
population on race um
and this was one question one of my
undergrads is working on this
looking at people's
perceptions of the differences between
race ethnicity and ancestry and this is
qual this is a qualitative question
open-ended question and so we coded and
these are the responses um we we got um
in terms of the definitions of those
words because you know these terms are
used interchangeably and we we still are
so confused about how we distinguish
them but that's not our conversation
today we're going to focus on race but
anybody can tell me quickly what you
what is one thing you notice on that
about on that bar graph
one thing that strikes you on that
they are
that's right yes that is definitely one
of the things that that is is striking
in this
um
on this anybody else anything else
[Music]
right
and what did most of them say they don't
know
ethnicity
right which we found interesting most
people did not know how to define
ethnicity they could tell you something
about race whether it was correct or not
they could give you a definition for
race and when we asked them about their
race they could tell us something when
we asked people about their ethnicity i
don't know
they give you their race mostly hispanic
people would say i you know they they
use race and ethnicity many of the
hispanics in the study the same thing
but most people and even we did we did
this in a pilot and it's the same thing
most people have no clue what ethnicity
is whether how to define it or what
their ethnicity might be
and that's something where we're
following up
on
more
we also see that for genetic and we
could look at genetic and physical as
similar
but for genetic of course
race more likely right most people
people were more likely to link um race
and genetics
when we asked the question about the
existence of biological human races
this is what we saw
so
we have gender left bright black white
and what we see and the line going
across
is the mean for all the other groups i
mean blacks and white were our largest
groups the other groups were small so we
we just we did them in terms of what
they're showing us on on these graphs
and we see that education
um
people with with less education were
more likely to think
that whether they were men
identified as as men or women were more
likely to think that biological races
exist we found that people who
identified as white
were more likely
to think that
that biological races
um
exist
we have a scale that we're in the
process of validating
um and we'd use this scale in this and
and on that scale looking at race and
genetics asking people various things
about the relationship between race and
genetics and this is how they scored um
and people who were black were more
likely to score higher on that scale
than than people who identified as white
younger people were more likely to score
higher which may not necessarily be very
surprising
um
and um
yeah there's just some of the findings
here when we ask people for their
their comments
um there are people who
um you know are thinking race needs to
go so much baggage
people who didn't even know what to say
because there is so much um
that they that they could think of many
people were said said they just never
even thought about these differences and
and um
and um
and wanted to know more
and then just like our other is
complicated it's complicated and we know
it's complicated and it's this
complexity
that has led me to do some of the work
i do i've become very interested in
complexity and this is a a um
a model that colleagues and i developed
um and published in 2009 this is when i
was at howard and this was part of an
nih grant we had
um and and and what we did in this in
this model
is utilize data mainly
most of the data were data related to
african americans
um
and looking at
um variables that influence health and
interactions
um and came up with this model looking
at
um
various domains
in terms of
we looked at genetics we looked at
um
where people are their identities their
theirs social and environmental
exposures
um
they're psychological
um
where's my
my cursor is all over the place but
anyway we looked at a range of
of variables here and their influences
on outcomes not just status of health
but drug response health perceptions a
range of responses um informed by by
data um
that we that in that literature and in
that paper in 2009
um
we put
out the idea which is an idea i've had
for a long time
about sickle cell disease
and looking at sickle cell disease as a
model
to help us understand
complexity gene environment interactions
now sickle cell disease
i'm going to just do a little bit for
those who may not know
about six cell disease
um
first the first known publication at
least in the u.s when i talked to my
african colleagues they're like we've
been talking about this thing for a long
time we just didn't know what to call it
right
and so we didn't and we weren't we
didn't have a journal to publish it yet
and so we say 1910 was the first
publication in the u.s
um on sickle cell disease
um
published by james herrick who
identified the first person first person
identified walter clement noel in the us
uh in in chicago he was a grenadine
dental student in chicago at university
of chicago
and and became ill and they found these
elongated
cells
and that and they were published and
over time
we've learned a lot about sickle cell
disease in 1949 linus pauling and others
told us about the molecular basis of
sickle cell disease that is a point
mutation in the hemoglobin gene and you
see here um this scheme shows
what we what we call
normal hemoglobin we you know we're
careful about how we use these words
normal right but we're just going to use
it today
and then and then cycle and it's one
change one
base pair change
um in the genetic code
from a t to an a that gives us a
different amino acid from glutamic acid
to valine and the production of this
different
amino acid gives us hemoglobin s which
is a sickle hemoglobin right normal
hemoglobin that one on the left the red
cells are pliable and soft and they can
slide through the vesicles the small
veins and capillaries the sickled cells
however become rigid because they've
lost oxygen the result of the of the
of the of the variant produces a
decreasing amount of oxygen cells become
sticky they clump together and going
through cells vesicles um capillaries
and veins
cause a lot of pain they cause blockage
what we call vassal occlusion
which is part of the hallmark of the
disease
we also learned in the 1950s
from ac allison about the link between
sickle hemoglobin
and malaria right and what you see here
uh on the left
is
uh historically where malaria was and on
the right
sickle cell
trait right sickle cell trait we also
learned i didn't say before the
inheritance of sickle cell disease is an
autosomal recessive disorder so both
parents have to have a trait
and when they have a child with every
child that those parents have if each of
them has a trait with every child
there's a 25 chance that they could have
a child with the disease
um
and it's the trait that is linked to
malaria right and then when people have
come together with a trait then they
could have a child with a disease so the
presence of sickle cell trait
sickle cell trait arose as part of
natural selection to protect people from
death from malaria so classic
case of natural selection and here we
see where malaria is today still mostly
in africa and some parts of of south
america but for most part of the world
it does not exist sickle cell disease is
also probably
probably the most racialized disease
their other diseases are racialized but
sickle cell disease has been
and this perception that sickle cell
disease is a black disease
um
has been part of
the problem
that people with the disease have in
terms of their treatment um and and
part of my interest i worked on six zone
disease in my graduate work and as a
genetic counselor at the sickle cell
center and got interested in very more
interested in diseases i saw families
with pain with with with um
with children with sickle cell disease
and the children i had i remember one
family with five children affected with
six so disease and each one of them was
different in terms of their outcomes one
child was pretty much symptom free you
wouldn't even know that they had six so
disease and then another one in the
hospital all the time and then another
one died early and that variability
struck me
and i found there's got to be and in in
grad school i learned about the genetic
factors that influenced that but i was
always also interested in what are the
other things um so the racialization of
sickle cell disease is a big part of the
story of the disease we can't talk about
it without the racialization so sickle
cell disease affects just about every
organ every organ system is affected and
again
is affected in some people some people
don't have a lot of symptoms but most
people will have some from your eye all
the way to your to your toes can be
affected as you see there
it's also global
there are about 20 million people
globally with sickle cell disease most
of them
are in three countries
in the
congo republic of the congo nigeria and
india
most most of them are in africa
right um and we see the numbers there
and and and and mostly um
countries below
the maghreb countries
in africa
and so we see sickle cell disease as a
global disease in the u.s about 100 000
people with the disease
we see a lot of inequities in sickle
cell disease and many people don't think
about the inequities and the disparities
in sickle cell disease because many
people say well we know it's
well some people think of it as a black
disease some people say we know it's not
a black disease but mostly black people
have it which is true
mostly people who identify as african at
least in the u.s but the disease is also
very common in greece there are some
parts of greece that have more sickle
cell disease than some parts of africa
south africa for example doesn't really
have sickle cell disease most of the
people there are people who come from
other parts of of the continent um and
so when we think about six cell diseases
global
turkey middle east uh india
very very much global
but in general both here in the u.s and
globally has received little attention
compared to other diseases in terms of
funding and and other things
and this was this is produced by the cdc
foundation showing some of the
disparities in terms of life expectancy
um returning to the hospital i talked
about pain the hallmark of the disease
more likely even when you compare sickle
cell disease with other diseases that
have pain associated with them their
studies there was a study done by
colleagues at hopkins looking at
patients with long bone fracture and
what happens very often is that people
with sickle disease because they suffer
from such severe pain have to take
narcotics for the most part to deal with
the pain and are always in the er for
the most part um and very often
um
they
as we go down here i'm not going to get
to go through all of these but patients
are often seen um as as drug seeking um
and in the u.s as we said most of the
patients are patients who identify as
african-american there are many patients
who identify as hispanic too with sickle
cell disease but that is one key
component of sickle cell disease
experience that that people have and i'm
interested in knowing do people across
the world in other countries have that
experience as i think about race and how
it plays out and then we also know that
the number of physicians who are willing
to see people with sickle cell disease
is also a small number some people just
don't want to just don't want to deal
with them
now in thinking about
factors that influence sick cell disease
we've long known that there are genetic
factors it's a classic mendelian single
gene disorder right
you can't get it unless you inherit
those those variants from from from both
of your parents and so there are these
genetic factors the hemoglobin genotype
whether you're ss they're about they're
over a thousand hemoglobin variants s is
the most severe and the one we talk
about here but there's c as well and s
with another abnormal hemoglobin will
result in sickle cell disease
but the genotype the haplotype and all
these are genetic factors but less
well-known
are non-genetic factors that influence
excel disease and these are some of them
climate um all
aspects of of climate and i'm gonna try
to wrap up soon
um that influenced the cell disease but
all of these and they're they're studies
that have looked at these
um
at these factors and this is a paper
published by pl and others from the uk
where they they
they created this image of some of the
genetic modifiers the non-genetic
modifiers
but what i found interesting in their
paper is that they never brought them
together right so we're looking at the
genetic modifiers up here we're looking
at the environmental modifiers down here
i have long been interested in bringing
all of those things together and this is
an image from a paper that we published
last year
um that has seven domains
and as you notice there are no
boundaries between those because what we
know is that all of these things are
operating together at the same time and
understanding that complexity is
challenging
but it's a must if we really want to
understand the mechanisms
of the disease and so the paper we
published
put forward this this this um this idea
of looking at sickle cell disease and we
used pain
as an example all of what you see there
is influence is informed by the
literature um the arrows
are are factors that exacerbate pain
the circles or factors that have been
shown to ameliorate pain so as we think
about health and disease
and and race and racism thinking about
fact not just factors that cause disease
or make disease worse
but also factors that can help
have a positive impact on our on our
health and outcomes both are equally
important and this was a timeline we
created looking at various factors as
they go up and down the pain is going up
going down as different factors
the factors from these domains and how
people's health is increasing as their
pain
decreases
and so this work in terms of looking at
the complexity and i'm going to move on
because i know i've got to
get a wrap-up um
soon um
is is something that
um we we've done in we just did a
preliminary study looking at at people
with six oh disease in jamaica cameroon
and south africa and well we did south
africa too but this publication was
focused on jamaica cameroon and the us
um and and and for various reasons we
couldn't do the comparisons we're
looking at existing data we wanted to
look at gene environment interactions
but for all kinds of reasons some sites
didn't have genetic information some
didn't have environmental so we just
picked one that had the most robust set
of data and that was jamaica and what we
found we found
associations in terms of age in terms of
of of atmospheric temperature rainfall
zinc
lower zinc
was a risk factor for pain and greater
poverty um so these were some factors
that we found um that uh influenced
severity of pain or increased severity
pain um we're surprised not to find any
differences across genotypes because the
genotypes are known to be
factors that influence severity so there
might be some things
that that we need to look at
at there i'm going to move very quickly
into talking about
race-based medicine
and and what you saw there was just the
assumptions that that underlie
race-based medicine right and race-based
medicine when i say race-based medicine
i'm thinking about practicing medicine
based on these racial categories how we
treat people the drugs that we give them
the treatments that we give them um
and the things that we think will work
best for them in terms of their their
health and the assumptions are that
races exist and that racist races
biological races exist that they differ
in their genetic components and that
these differences influence those those
health health outcomes so i'm going to
talk very quickly about vital
which is a drug the first drug approved
by the fda to treat a specific
racial group has everybody in here heard
about bidel
some people have anybody never never
heard about baidal
oh we have some people who never heard
about it okay we're going to take a
couple of minutes just a couple because
i don't want to take away from y'all i
can't talk about that in a couple
minutes but i'm going to try to do it
um so so vital
is a combination of two generic drugs
isosorbidi nitrate and hydrolysis and
hydrochloride these are two
generic drugs that have been used by
cardiologists over the years since the
1970s or before to treat heart failure
and they've used these com these two two
generic drugs in different combinations
to treat people with heart failure and
when i say treat people
black white yellow green blue people
right everybody they use them and they'd
use did in different combinations to
treat different people
in the 1970s a researcher at minute
universe minnesota is a clinician j khan
started using putting these two drugs
together in particular combinations and
over time he he sold their pat the
rights to that to a company called
nitromed got a patent on it and it's a
long story they got three packs on it
they appeared applied to the fda
in the 80s to get it approved to treat
heart failure
um
in blacks because some study that they
had done had shown that it works better
in black people and other people and
they thought okay we need to get a the
fda to approve this for us to treat
black people applied to the fda 96 the
fda turned them down and said no you
need to go do a study that will show
that it works better for black people
than other people so they designed the
study called the aheph
african-american heart failure trial
and the trial
started in 2001
um and in 2003 they discontinued the
trial there was a placebo trial so there
were half of the people a thousand fifty
people were in this study half of them
got placebo
and standard treatment and the standard
treatment was either ace inhibitors or
diuretics right so they got a placebo
and standard and the other half got
standard
and vital
right
and so in 2003 they ended the trial
because the group that was getting vital
they know when they compared the two
the group was getting vital had a
reduction
of death from heart failure of 43
big percentage right so they had to end
it because it would have been unethical
to continue so the end of the trial 2003
um at that time you know sought to get
another patent they did get another
patent they had three had three patents
that the whole patent story is a whole
big story jonathan khan who's probably
written the most
on this um has actually written a book
on vital
so you can look him up jonathan khan if
you want to learn more about that
but the interesting thing about bite and
one of the interesting things about
vital is that as i said before it's the
first
drug
ever
to be approved by the fda for a
particular
racial group
um the the company nitromed once in 2005
it was approved by the fda
in 2008 the company went out of business
and and a couple other companies bought
it is now owned by a company called
arbor pharmaceuticals which is where
this came from on their website so
they're still marketing the drug
there are a couple of
people are you know
we don't have a ton of data my team and
i have done some some empirical studies
on physicians use of vital this is a
study we did with cardiologists
but there are really not many studies on
bad and i'm trying to understand why it
failed so early right
the naacp the congressional black caucus
the associate of back cardiologists all
supported
um this at the time
now i talked to many of them and many of
them didn't know that this was what the
company was going for to get it approved
to treat a a specific racial group i
testified at the hearing for this for
that for that for that the approval my
colleagues and i at howard i was at
howard at the time and you know we were
you know black folks over on this side
said do not approve this drug just for
black people and then i we have the
congressional black policies over the
state
we've been discriminated against give us
our drug it's our time we've got to
address health disparities
right very very interesting
um hearing um the fda ended up approving
it this was a study that we had done
there's so much i could say about this
but we don't have time
this this these are some findings from a
study we did uh some colleagues and i
did into 2019. we just published another
paper with some findings that were
similar but what we found is that some
cardio cardiologists are still using
bridal um but for most of them they give
it to anybody for whom it will work is
approved just for
self-identified blacks that's what the
indication says right
and so people are
are proving it off label
are prescribing it off label to other
people for whom it works as we see there
not only given to black patients um and
for many of them the primary criterion
was not race in terms of why they
prescribed it this was the indication
what else was going on with that person
in terms of of their health um and then
there are some that believe that it was
appropriate to do that for the fda to do
that
and others said that bottom line is
lots of questions among physicians even
about baidal and whether this should
have been done but it's been done it's
still the only case for which this has
been done lots of issues there um and we
may talk about some of them later about
why the fda saw it fit to do this for
this drug and not for other drugs right
for other studies where there were no
black people over the years right and so
their thing was that this study was just
done with black people and so it can
only be a proof of black people well
well studies a long time ago didn't
include any black people and we get all
those drugs that all of us are using
right and so why is it different so
lots and lots of
of issues there i'm gonna and this was
um from that same study that our doctor
said to us that my white patients would
walk in and say give me that black drug
is working for me
they don't patients don't they just want
to know what's working for them right so
we put these labels on these things and
people many people don't really care so
in terms of race-based medicine the
paper that colleagues and i wrote about
precision medicine there's this all this
talk about precision medicine and we
wrote this paper it was a question and
we talked in that paper
we talked you used some examples but
also talked about what it would take for
us to move beyond race and whether we
can even do that
um then some colleagues
um
the same year um wrote a piece on taking
race out of human genetics uh studies
and that's been a big concept
conversation about whether genetic and
genomic studies should be even using the
concept
of race
and then we have this study that was
published um
a little later last year where where
some geneticists and others are saying
hold up a minute not so quick with
getting rid of race there may be some
utility to this and these are
geneticists and they give some studies
about um how race even more than genetic
ancestry in some cases
was predictive of of health outcomes so
there is there continues to be the
debate
um about this and whether we use this in
genetic studies and i i co-chair a
national academies committee that is
looking at this there are issues about
use of race and other other such
descriptors in genetic studies i'm going
to move on quickly because i know we i
want to do the q a and we are past time
um
this slide and the next couple of slides
are really just about where we are in
the conversations so there's been a lot
of conversations recently in this since
2020
um in the death of george floyd and a
lot of things that have been happening
about how we use race and medicine and
about algorithms you've heard about the
egfr
and how these algorithms are used to
describe to determine who gets what
treatment right and that these
algorithms are based on ideas about race
so egfr
um
they estimated glomerular
filtration rate and this algorithm that
has been used to give different
treatments to black patients from white
patients because of the prolonged
standing perception that white back
patients have more muscle mass than
white patients and so they excrete more
creatinine so you look at the level of
creatinine and you have to adjust
your algorithm because black people have
more muscle mass right so these ideas
long-standing but they they influence
what we do today so
wrapping up i really am wrapping up now
um where do we go from here i presented
a lot of issues a lot of problems um
and and i have here what i'm call what i
call the biomedical
ecosystem
as all of the entities and these may not
be all but some of the key ones
that
have to
be involved
in any efforts to change
what i've been talking about this whole
time
to change how we use race in society
in health research
in clinical practice
it takes more than just the geneticists
or the social scientists bringing us
back to our conversation about how we
think about knowledge and making
knowledge
and and and how how we make
ethical knowledge right it has to be
informed by multiple voices for us to
think through
all all of the issues and and one of the
areas that i i'm going to talk about
just really quickly is the area of
training is a course that i i teach at
duke called race genomics in society
where i bring all of these
things together bringing genetics and i
do a primary on genetics and talk about
how genetics is influences and how
people think about
athletics and intelligence and skin
color and help them understand how these
things come to be
and and and what genetics says or not
and how society um says about about
these things and then talking about help
and this fall i'm always doing different
things with this class and this this
fall last fall
i i had the experience
of a lifetime where i asked the students
and i've kept that course at 100
students so there this semester this
fall we had 96 students who 98 started
in 96 of the class and one of their
assignment was to assignments was to
create a piece of art
at the end of the class for throughout
the class but a piece of art that
represented
what their what they took away and it
has to be had to be a piece of art that
brought together
the the genetics and the social and
all of the factors right and they could
focus on one module
say skin color or they could do a
combination ancestor testing skin color
intelligence whatever
and the students created they had an
eight and a half eleven i worked with
people in my arts um department and it
was four discussion sections and they
created these art and these are the four
four panels
and i can't tell and each of them had to
write a 150 word statement that
described their piece
um it is now on display in our
rubinstein art center which is our big
center art center at duke
and i can't tell you what it means for
me to see
what they wrote not because it says
anything about me
but because it tells me
about the future it gives me hope
for the future and how these students
took this information in and how it
informs how they think about race and
racism
and what they will do in the future so i
i could talk forever about that i sat
and i read all of these and i'm thinking
did they really get this from from this
fascinating fascinating and then some of
them would say i'm no artist when you
see what they create
i said we were all it was just great i'm
gonna end with a slide by a colleague of
mine
building on how we teach how we teach
about race and genetics because for me
how we communicate the information and i
say we i'm talking about faculty in the
academy and others who teach and how we
help people understand
social race and biological race and the
difference between the two and what
happens when we conflate the two right
and teaching people so they understand
and so teaching about this has been
one of my life mission and a colleague
of mine brian donovan who who works um
in in in colorado um at the biological
sciences curriculum study organization
research scientist there has been he he
works they work primarily with with k
through 12. um and when i finish my race
genomics and society class i always we
always do a so what at the end of the
class and invariably students say
this information needs to be taught
earlier right i didn't learn this until
i got here
and and brian and his team are they've
been doing studies and have done studies
that show that how we teach
and i talked about mendelian disorders
and how we teach about mendelian
disorders and how we teach about the
presence and absence of genes and how
that leads to an outcome and needing to
teach about complexity right how we
teach students at all levels influences
and they've done randomized trials that
show that students who learn about
complexity have different ideas about
the relationships between people
about what people are capable of and
what genetic differences mean or don't
mean
um
and and he and i are collaborating on
some getting ready to collaborate on
some things so thinking of the ethics of
knowledge making toward a more humane
genetics how we think about justice how
we think about beneficence and
non-maleficence in our teaching about
race
and genetics and how those things come
together leading us to a more humane
genetics and a more humane way
of thinking about
the relationships between these things
but a more humane way of living with one
another
i'm going to stop there
thank you
all right brian i know brendan i know
i've taken all your time
well thank you professor royal for that
um
i wanted to remind everyone there's a
reception uh we'll go until about 5 30
and then there is a reception afterwards
right right outside
so
upstairs great thank you
great
yes you can get as much water as you can
uh
thank you all for your patience when i
went on and on there
oh all right
um well oh thank you for that again
thank you to the uh organizers thank you
uh professors cohen and near really
really enjoy and obviously thank you
professor royal for
uh solving the problem of scientific
racism for us over the last hour
uh really quite thrilling and i think uh
there ah there's i think
there's so much in there there's so many
directions to take and i think you did a
beautiful job kind of communicating not
just the topic but the topic through
your work which i think was really quite
impressive how you've been able to
address it we're going to start with
something invariably you've thought
about
with regards to the way that we address
this problem in contemporary settings
there's this notion that
we're just going to add more data to the
problem and we will solve it we seek
more genomes and more genomes and more
genomes or perhaps a little more
charitably we get more diverse genomes
for more diverse backgrounds and i think
if we understand more and more genomes
we'll kind of solve the problem that way
and obviously some people who like we
one respects even take that approach you
know maybe even thinking about the
problem in a humane way as you would
articulate it i want you to respond to
that and what is your take on that
approach to these problems
okay so brian which mic am i using not
the
not the the lover this one right yeah
all right so i can take this one up
okay so to answer your question brandon
um
you know i think
there are some
cases
there are some cases where we might need
more data
um
but i wouldn't say we need more genomic
data
i would say we need more of the other
data
but we need more genomic data on some
things
there's some things where
and and when i say some things there's
some
issues where we don't need any more data
we don't need any more data i think
and some will argue with me
to tell us that humans don't have
biological race
right i mean there are people who say
well
what if we because we often say humans
are a young species so we don't you know
we haven't lived long enough to happen
people say well what if we look for a
million years
from now
we we might have some
some biological reason like we'll think
about that then
right now
we don't have it um so in terms of that
issue and how we understand human
genetic variation and human variation
uh i mean there's a lot we can
understand about human into humans still
to to be understood with regard to human
variation but with with regard to the
issue of race um i i think we have the
information we need right now
the information that tells us about our
common human origin the emotion tells us
about frequency and and all i think we
have enough
to to drive home those messages to
people who don't know i'm not naive
enough to think and even in teaching
race genomics in society i'm not naive
enough to think that just giving people
that information is going to take care
of the racism problem right
it's it's not in and of itself is going
to take care of the nation
but it has a role to play in our
national survey that i showed you 54 of
the u.s population believe that they're
biological races what they understand by
biological race races we didn't get into
that but we we will
um
but the ideas
that surround
that
knowledge
is are important right and so helping
people understand what
what what how we're related to each
other as humans um
is important it's still important
but we have a lot more work to do in
society but i think it's it's going to
take the geneticist and the social
scientists and all of us working
together to solve the racism uh problem
um collecting more genetic data
and genomic data can tell us something
but i think in the end we need to
collect more data on the context within
which genes operate right to help us
understand this complexity
and context broadly defined not just
what we eat um but but but the racism
that affects us and influences our
health and help us understand how those
stressors
interact with
genetic or other factors the influencer
that that complexity we don't understand
fully and we're not even close to
understanding it so in that case for
that i think we need more data
you know fascinating um
thank you for that i'm gonna jump around
a little bit if that's okay and i think
you set the precedent for that with
where you're able to elegantly tie so
many parts of this conversation together
uh i think you talked about testifying
in the
uh or in for the bite in the bible trial
kind of decision and you you
you outlined this setting where you and
your colleagues
were
you know
articulating these points about the
problems with the proving bible and you
were in opposition
to these problems you know lawmakers
black lawmakers the congressional black
caucus who were in favor and i think
that's a kind of a good microcosm for
the way these kind of conversations
happen where right there is a kind of a
social justice component
to the right this desire to reify race
and i want to hear it now
i want to now take to your classroom or
invariably you're able to teach this
effectively so i want to know how you
were able to right i know how you think
about it because you just told us how
you think about it and how you reconcile
that but how are you able to communicate
to reconcile that conflict with a lot of
people because it's one that we that is
a barrier i think to the the country
understanding in
this complexity
that's a really good question brandon
you know i
i have talked with my colleagues in the
cbc
and at the naacp about
um
their
you know myopic way of looking at this
of course
they have an agenda
that in some ways different from mine
right and their agenda is to ensure
that
the policies that are put in place
in their minds benefit black people
when i talk to them they understand the
scientific racism argument that we were
trying to make right that approving this
drug
just for black people
is sending the message that many already
believe that black people are different
biologically and need their own drug
right
and and so i had them think about that
and
for them it's like we know that
but
you know but we we still need our
some attention
right it's like
um
it's it's it's a tough one
um
but it requires
those kinds of conversations to get us
across the divides
right um
when i talk to them about their roles
in the community
and how they need to think about
the roles that they play in reifying
these notions and how the people within
the black community black community i
use that term
in quotes
look up to them to protect their
interests and if their interests at
least in my view are not informed
um
are not
are not looking at the big picture
right um in their minds they're looking
at the big picture which is social
justice i'm like i'm looking at social
justice too
but we we need to figure it out the
problem the thing is that if it's a
proof forever for everyone black people
will get it too
right you're right
it's a different problem
i'll get it too
but but but the see when i think about
justice and social justice
i think about justice for everybody so i
think about the hispanic people who
won't get it because it's just the proof
of black people
but the other issue is that
they're not it's not gonna work for
every black person as we saw in the
trial so what about those people who are
black
who won't respond well to bideal will
they get a drug
right so once we go down this path
it it it may look like it's serving a
purpose
and doing what they think it's going to
do
but the downsides
um to not just people who identify as
black and you know they say they're
thinking that okay we've given them
their drug we don't have to try to find
another one that might work for them now
how baidal has played out in terms of
arbor pharmaceuticals is you know the
company's marketing it doctors are still
prescribing it
many black people are not taking it
right i remember in 2005 when it was
approved in 2006 and i would talk to
people i was talking to this this man
who
he was a uncle of a friend of mine and
she said you need to talk to my uncle
because he won't take vital
and i said and he has heart failure
and and i talked to him i said
so why won't you take the drug she's
like they they developed that just for
us
oh no i'm not gonna take it
right and so we think we're and and for
many people that's probably why the drug
didn't survive
and also the drug there are so many
stories the many doctors were not
prescribing it for the patients because
it was too expensive but they're black
patients
right and so so there's so many issues
that surround the it's the first drug
that's done that this has happened to so
it's the only example we have
and we haven't done enough research to
really understand
all the
the facets
of what is happening with vital and so i
think it requires conversation i've had
conversations with my colleagues at the
cbc and the naacp
about this um and over time i mean they
got upset because the drug the price of
the drug was so high
the drug had the highest markup of any
fda approved 700 percent
after it was approved by the by the fda
700 and going into this people were
worried and were saying to nitro med you
know this is gonna you sure this this is
you know black people if you say
defining for black people and many
people who not able to afford it you
need to make it affordable and say oh
it's going to be affordable well it was
not
right and so so the cost became an issue
and so i think when we start when when
we when we think about
um how
how how these things play out
um we have to have a broad view
of of of of things and
and and prioritize you know figure out
what's really important
no i mean really really
important i mean because every time
there's this big there's a lot of big
public hiccups around talking about race
david reich talks they always use
disease disease right these types of
things about how uh and i think the way
you've been able to uh disentangle that
is really profound i'll ask one last
question and then i'll take uh and then
i'll take questions from the audience uh
while we have a few minutes um
just i want to get in just go to sickle
cell anemia i think your work there was
my introduction to your work and i think
what's beautiful about it and certainly
professor nir right i think we teach
that as the canonical
mendelian disease right and i think we
have these other models of genetics
where everything else is more complex
but sickle cell is very very very simple
and i think what your work has done is
blown that open and articulated that
even that when i now i think to myself
wow is is mendelian disease even a
proper term for things right maybe we
need an entire new lexicon to describe
genetics as a whole so you you you
you're succeeding in making all of our
jobs more difficult so i i wanna
i wanna i want i want you to lean into
that and are there other diseases you
talk about that this is not the only
racialized disease right as you say
maybe the most but kind of lean into
that a little bit and what are some
other kind of thoughts you have in that
direction or other diseases of that kind
okay so
good question
um so there's cystic fibrosis which is
also racialized but not in the same way
right but very similarly um black people
who have sexist fibrosis they're
misdiagnosed just like white people who
have sickle cell disease are
misdiagnosed right and by snagged doses
as we know it can be a major problem um
but cystic fibrosis has the same kind of
a complexity you know smoke exposure and
ta-da i just published a paper well it
was published last year as well with
colleagues at the national institute of
environmental health sciences looking at
sickle cell disease cystic fibrosis
huntington disease and parkinson's
disease as for monogenic diseases i mean
parkinson's is you know a little more
variable in terms of inheritance um
and looking at environmental factors so
the paper was on environmental
influences on on mendelian diseases and
for us to start thinking about mendelian
diseases uh different but your point
about about
whether mendelian is even a way of
thinking about i mean guess we could say
mendelian but probably not monogenic
right
mendelian still helps us predict
predict inheritance right and and that's
really the the the pattern is the
patterns of inheritance um so the
patterns are still there in terms of how
you get it because you can't get it
these diseases without um i mean
parkinson's again is a little different
um but huntington and sickle cell and cf
you can't you
at least at least right now as far as we
know you can only get it by inheriting
those variants um
so so how we think about about disease
and health
right
somebody who has
two
s hemoglobins
but have no symptoms have no
complication they're pretty much fine
do we say they have six cell diseases do
we say they have a disease well you know
we may or may not right
um and how we think about health
and disease all of those questions are
part of this this this issue of
complexity and how we we understand
complexity and the more we look at so so
my thing has always been all diseases
are complex
right all diseases are complex they
don't just happen they're
multi-factorial all of them right some
may be a little more complex than others
or some we may be able to predict
their their inheritance a little bit
better than other diseases i mean we
know most breast cancers are sporadic
but about 10
and prostate cancer are hereditary right
um
and so so thinking about diseases
all of them as being complex and the
levels of complexity right
um for the for the mendelian disorders
or monogenic disorders the environmental
and and social factors may play a lesser
not as prominent role in their etiology
but in the pathophysiology
they play a major role and the more we
understand those things the better we
are able to i mean sickle cell disease
is also the thing at the top of the list
for gene editing that's right right
that's right and my thing is that even
when we think about who's going to
respond well
to curative therapies
we need to think about these other
factors it's not just plugging in a gene
here and everything is going to be fine
right so
yeah no so much great um now thank you
for that uh we have a few minutes left
so we'll take a question or two if we
can from the audience i think no no no
we have a question
um
very good question
what i would say and i did not talk
about racism as much
but
i always say there's no race without
racism
racism created race
right and racism is what brings this
hierarchy right and these ideas about
inferiority and superiority that drove
the creation of race right so we had
these ideas about who was most beautiful
we blooming back whomever about who was
most beautiful and then we created
something to justify those ideas so
racism and race to me are intertwined
they're not separate they're not
separable
um
and and you're right i think
in many cases we talk about race as a
category without talking about the
racism that goes along with it and i
guess i did some of that today talking
about race and not so much the racism
but but for me they're they're they're
all part of when i talk about 6-0
disease and and and how people are
treated in the clinic it's because
they're racialized that they're treated
in a particular way
and so they they're they're one and the
same
to me and so if we if we even if we say
race is a social construct it's so and i
i
i i hesitate to you i know i rarely say
that raises a social construct as
opposed to saying it's socially
constructed right uh we made it up right
um and and and using it as as a verb as
opposed to a noun
uh puts the onus on who created it and
on the creation um so i i agree with you
that that the racism is what we need to
address and the racism
is what to address the racism in my view
will take us
coming together and getting
getting beyond the separation
that has caused these divides and
helping us as i say very often is to see
ourselves in the face of the other
and to interact more with each other
any other questions from the from the
audience
don't talk so much you have no questions
sorry about that no i think there's a
there's one let's see if we can
um
for a long time
that
was like
categories related
based on the surveys you presented to us
in the first part and your experience
where do you see
they use the phrase
so i think that um
the conversations about race and racism
and the conversations about gender and
sex
um there are some similarities in those
conversations in terms of
of um
of utilizing biology
as a marker of difference now but but
they're different in terms of how we we
use that i mean i know
researchers
who who study homosexuality for example
and who
who who identify as gay and their work
is intended to show that
this is a biological trait
right race is different
right
for race we're trying to show that what
we're calling race
and racism is socially constructed so
biology is not
is not the driver of those differences
so there are differences in those
conversations and in the underlying
science
of those of those conversations there's
also a difference with race
in my view and and i i i don't apologize
for this i think there's something
different about race
from gender from sexuality and any of
those other identities
i know about intersectionality as well
but
if we do not focus if we focus on race
and we can address race then in my view
we can address everything else
if we don't single race out
and address it
or at least try to address it
it constantly gets subsumed on all these
other things
and never really gets the attention it
needs and race this country
and parts of the world too
is built on
that idea
it is built on that separation
and so there is an urgent need to
address race
like no other identity in my view
and so that's my perspective on on race
and racism in light of these other isms
that we're that we're trying to address
um
the issue of
um
i'm blacking on the article other
question now
all right so i will i will say very
quickly um
that that i can't say a whole lot about
that because i'm on this national
academies committee that's looking at
that and we can't say much of you know
people here have been on national
academy
[Laughter]
you're
bowed to secrecy um so we're beginning
that work um
but i can say
that and the committee is comprised of
social scientists epidemiologists
historians geneticists and others
i think in the next 10 years we will see
at least i hope
we will see a shift
in how
genetic studies are done
in light of what we know about race
and i think if we see a shift in genetic
studies
that would inform what happens in
biomedical research at large
i think genetics and the role that
genetics plays in the creation of race
and the
maintenance of this notion of race i
think if genetics and geneticists
and genomicists change the way they do
research
and when i say change i'm talking about
everything from
you know whether we use race or not but
how we think about the role of genes
in outcomes
health outcomes traits whatever the
outcomes are how geneticists think about
and design their studies
i think will inform
what other disciplines do and i think a
change is on the horizon
i hope
it is
great well join me in
congratulating thank you
thank you
thank you
yes
please be my friend